thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
lords
knights
squires
and all other manner of people
that by the command of our lord the king
of france
it is strictly prohibited
on pain of death and the loss of
property
for anyone here to be armed
or to carry a sword or dagger unless he
be one who has the express permission
of our lord the king
each man is to fight
on horseback and on foot
armed in the manner that pleases him
with any weapon or device of attack
defense
except
for weapons or devices of equal design
or made with charms or spells or
any other thing that is forbidden by god
and holy church to all good christians
by the combatant shall carry on to the
field of battle any arms that have been
forged with spells
charms enchantments or any other
evilness
and so shall the manufacturer be
punished as an enemy of god
or as a tracer
or as a matter of fact
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
knights proceed
uh
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
i am telling the truth
i want him to answer for what he has
done
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
can this man
do nothing but evil to me
i am innocent of the crime
[Music]
i request a duel to the death
the accusation is false
what happened to me is wrong
who is your lost
one of us is lied
let us let god decide
confess
the last duel we did our only vetoes
october 15th tickets on sale now
[Music]
you